So the monies are not going to flow to local journalism. Um,
but the local journalism,
sustainability act had so many smart things in it. Uh,
and you have to ask yourself if you're a member of Congress,
how can you be against trying to make local journalism function in your
community? Uh,
because theoretically they'd be helping cover you
like cover it, cover the issues you're working on that you care about. Um,
so for the life of me,
I don't understand why you only have 50 or 60 members of Congress.
It's bipartisan too. Cause a lot of the places that have lost their papers,
the fastest are more rural red States. Uh, you know, like,
like they, they see this problem just as clearly. Um,
so I'd love to, yeah, so this should be universal.
And one of the reasons we're going to have this conversation with you is trying
to push this because I want people to pass a local journalism sustainability
act. So, so for the folks that are,
are wondering how the heck can you reverse this tide?
Like what is in the local journalism sustainability act that would help fill
this one to $3 billion gap?
Um, so, uh, I, Steve is really clever.
He was, uh, worked at the,
the FCC and he did this like important report
documenting what was coming,
everything that was coming actually he's the one who really helps us get to the
one to $3 billion number because he's identified the critical information areas,
cost it out a way to a model of thinking about what are the key things that are
missing. And he's also identified a lot of safe ways. Um,
this is more recently now safe ways to direct money, to,
to news,
without fear that the government is going to control the
coverage.
Yeah. W w I have to say that concern is so overblown because we all watch
NPR, uh, you know, it's like,
do you really think that there's some government bureaucrat being like,
you know, like stop this Andrew Yang guy in his tracks,
like, um, you know, it's like,
like the fact that people are so concerned that if government touches it,
then all of a sudden we'll wind up in big brothers zone. Um,
but it just strikes me as, um, paranoid, frankly. It's like,
like you, you have models in other countries.
You're the BBC that's freaking publicly funded. Uh, you know,
it's been going on for decades and they managed to irritate politicians of every
Stripe. Uh, so there, there's no reason to think that,
especially if we're remote,
like if the federal government sends money to Tucson,
you're telling me that some bureaucrats going to be like, Hey folks in Tucson.
But like, we've got a school board candidate. We have our eye on like that,
you know, like that, that that's not, um, it's not anyway.
I think that the reason people are paranoid is that there is like,
there are propaganda efforts afloat that are working that are
privately initiated and we have, um, you know, a president.
That's why we need to do this because you're seeing private propaganda fill the
gap, you know? So, so having a nonprofit or public funding model, um,
to me makes sense. And a lot of this stuff in, um, in,
so I'm looking over here for some references because I want to get some of the
facts, right. Um, so the local journalism,
sustainability act has so many fun measures in it, um,
that I thought were genius. Like you said, very, very clever. So number one,
everyone gets a $250 refundable tax credit to pay for a subscription to a local
news source. So essentially you, you sign up for local news, it's free for you.
Uh, number two,
any small business gets a $5,000 credit to buy local advertising.
How fun is that?
That's one of Steve's most genius ideas too,
is that there's already a lot of government money that supports
advertising. And so we can take,
we can actually assemble a lot of money just by directing like public health
messaging to the places that actually by the way happen to be the most trusted
sources, local news.
Cause that's another thing like we trust the media except their local media.
Except local media. We all instinctively trust local media more. Um,
so to your point, It is more trustworthy.
It tends to be more objective and unifying. And that's why it's, uh,
it's depolarizing number three,
federal advertising budgets spent on local media organizations, uh,
and tax credits to maintain journalists and staffers number four,
three to one, a matching donation for any journalism, nonprofit.
So if you gave to your local nonprofit paper or whatnot,
you'd get matching funds. Number five,
define public service journalism as a tax deductible activity.
The one I loved the most,
number six was an opportunity to recede papers from private equity
funds, um,
that have gotten gobbled up or you could try and replant it in the community.
So here's what happens. You, you have, um,
thousands of family owned papers and cities around the country that got
consolidated into a conglomerate at some point it's called good net or, uh,
or one of these. Um,
and then ganache fell on hard times and was then bought by a
private equity fund or hedge fund at South private equity fund typically. Um,
and the private equity fund then owns a bunch of papers and then rings them for
cash. They look around and say, Ooh, like I have economies of scale. Um,
and then if someone raised their hand is like,
I'd like to report on my local school board and be like, well,
that has zero economies of scale, so no you're out. Um,
but, but now they're looking around for an exit. They're looking around saying,
what the heck do I do with my investment? Because this has not worked out.
Even my ringing for cash ruthlessness has not worked out.
And so if you give them an easy way out and say,
why don't just give that paper back to the community with five Oh one C3,
there's some local stakeholders and we'll cash you out.
Not so you make out like a bandit, but that,
that you actually make it out alive. Um,
that would be such an enormous win.
I thought this was the most genius idea and the whole thing.
Oh, well, thank you. I wrote it. No I didn't. Um, but I agree.
I really agree. I think you're totally right. The, um,
those are the group of us that were advising Steve and working with him on this
are very concerned about what the risk is also for the exit that
these, um,
private equity firms are gonna pursue that own a significant number of the
highly trusted brands in our country.
And we know that there's a big risk of a bad outcome because we know as
you alluded to that, there are bad actors who are, uh, on, on both.
I mean, bad actors,
PR propagandists advocacy efforts that are starting
new local news brands and allowing them to spew partisan
nonsense, um,
instead of fact-checked stories that actually bring people together.
And so those actors, you know, exist out there. There is a fear that is,
I don't think unwarranted that the, when the exit happens,
the papers go into the wrong hands. And so I thought Steve's idea here.
The replanting idea is really a genius idea to, um,
because it says let's incentivize a different outcome with.
An example from the presidential trail that maybe folks, um, uh,
will take to, uh,
the main paper that all the presidential candidates wanted to, um,
get coverage in was the Des Moines register, uh,
because it's the biggest circulation in Iowa.
And obviously I was the first state and the rest of it.
So we can just hang out with them all the time, um, or try to.
And so they wrote a good story about you. You are very, very pleased and, uh,
like your staff was very happy. De Moines register was bought by one of these,
uh, private equity firms, uh, and like tacked onto its, you know,
several hundred newspaper collection
while I was running. And so the journalist I was talking to was there,
it was like, well, we're not sure what's going to happen. Now.
We just got new ownership and like, it wasn't like a hip hip, hooray,
we got new ownership. It was like, Oh, like, you know,
I might lose my job kind of situation. Um, so,
so these are the folks that we've been relying upon, um,
for generations to help vet,
uh, national candidates who come through. Uh,
and so if you start doing a number on even massive pillars of local
journalism, like the Des Moines register, like where, where do you,
where does it end? It ends in tears, uh, really,
or it ends in an information wasteland. And like you said,
propagandists will fill that.
And I'm really worried right now. And I actually started a third, um,
pro organization, um, the last month because, uh, okay. Think back to,
um, 2000, the last time we had a contested presidential election,
which it possible that we're going to have again. Um,
and it came down to Florida. Um, the, the apparatus at that time of the,
of the newspapers in Florida was so strong and robust, like,
um, in the Miami Herald, I think had about 350 person newsroom at the time.
And they just went to town, making sure that, um, you know,
people understood what a hanging Chad was and they were in the room watching the
Chad's hang or whatever was actually going on. And, and that's,
that's like really, um,
you can't underestimate the difference between what the, the rest of us were.
We were just to kind of sitting at home, watching CNN here or,
or whatever we're watching now, um, Twitch here, uh,
when we're having it explained to us what, what is going on.
If there are people who are in the national stage have that behind
them have like all that 350 person newsroom that like understands
the,
the arcane details of local politics and local election administration versus
today, the Miami Herald newsroom is under a hundred people.
It's probably about 50 people. I mean, that's,
that's just like unreal to think about what's going to happen.
And it's like, we are in a much more insecure and unstable, um,
situation in terms of, uh, challenges to the integrity of the election.
Because one of the two candidates for president has already decided he doesn't
trust the outcome.
Plus a pandemic has made a lot of Americans wonder if they can trust the
outcome, adding on to that, like the history of voter suppression.
And that, that has been kind of opened up a little bit with,
by certain court moves. And so all of that, um,
is really scary situation like even right now,
because the people that are going to be explaining all of this to us have even
less firsthand independent accounts to rely on, which is why.
He said, they'll all be parachuting. And then, uh, you know,
you get there and like, who's there, what's the record.
And we already saw that happen in the primaries people, the, the, you know, you,
you, it, I love journalists. I am a journalist. And I want to say,
you can always believe journalists,
but you actually can't always believe journalists because sometimes they do
parachute and we do do that. And we don't know what we're talking about.
And it's dangerous to say,
to scare people about things that you don't actually need to be scared about,
but it's also, um, dangerous to,
to relieve big people feel relief when they shouldn't. I mean, it's just a bad,
bad situation. So, um, so the, I was like up, yeah.
I think journalists have been getting a bad rap. Um,
but I think a lot of the bad rap they've been getting does not apply to local
journalists earlier point it's like we,
we chose sort of trust local journalists in a different way than we do. Um,
some of the national media figures and the national media figures,
a lot of the economic incentives are around feeding into the polarization
narratives, unfortunately, and those incentives do not tend to exist locally.
Like if you're a small town paper,
the last thing you're going to do is being like,
we're the small town paper that only half of you are going to like.
Your recipe for success.
I mean, like obviously there's exceptions to every rule,
but the truth is that. Yeah, I agree with you. And that's so,
so I started a project Andrew called vote beat where we are deploying
local reporters because in the pandemic we've seen just hundreds and hundreds of
reporters for a load from their jobs who have, um,
for local reporters who have this deep,
trusted relationships in their communities. They have a lot of local knowledge,
but they're not working. And then there's this craziness that we have to cover.
So yeah.
You're matching the resources to the need nicely done. Uh, and,
and it's one reason why we have to act fast Elizabeth,
because these reporters expertise will not be there forever. Uh,
you know, the ability to replant these papers will not last forever.
Um, w w we have a window of time that we have to run through a window
of opportunity. Uh, and I,
I applaud you for leading on this issue. Um,
certainly before I'd figured it out, um,
we need to try and get more resources to the American journalism project.
We need to pass the local journalism sustainability act. If we do that,
then we'd have a real chance, um,
at having people like you covering important issues
in communities for decades and generations, instead of seeing it with her away.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notification so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.